Harvard has rescinded its admission of
well-known conservative activist Kyle
cash of over leaked chats of lewd jokes
that he and his friends made when they
were 16 years old we will examine what
this means for the American University
and how conservatives can fight back
then President Trump endorses a
constitutional amendment to ban flag
burning and almost all of the
conservative commentators instantly
condemned the idea as anti-american I
will explain the case for the amendment
because I am NOT most conservative
commentators finally 2020 Democrat
presidential candidate Pete Budaj edge
plays the gay card perfectly all that
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot to get to today first and foremost
the new I guess it's not news but the
obvious fact that Harvard sucks we'll
get to that in a second but first
support for the Michael Knowles show
comes from our friends at rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans finding the
right house is not easy you are telling
me I have been looking for houses
especially in LA it is awful the process
is opaque and terrible to go through
luckily finding the right mortgage can
be easy
rocket mortgage is doing more to help
you understand the home buying process
so you can get exactly what you need
because it's not just a mortgage it is
your mortgage and they have found a
better way the team of mortgage experts
there is obsessed with finding a better
way which means that their number one
goal is to make the home buying process
smoother for you it's already terrible
it's already a very difficult process
and you got to get the house that your
wife likes and the one that you like and
it's in the good neighborhood with the
good schools don't make it more
complicated rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way Quicken Loans has
helped millions of Americans achieve
their dream of home ownership it's
worked for them it'll work for you when
you are ready to purchase the home of
your dreams they can help you - when you
work with them you get more than just a
loan because rocket mortgage is much
more than just a lender gets started
online at rocket mortgage com / null
scam - wles Equal Housing lender
licensed in all 50 states and the nmls
consumer access door number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage very easy
Harvard sucks Harvard has just rescinded
its acceptance of Kyle Kashyap you know
Kyle Kyle's a friend of the show he's
come on here once or twice Kyle he was
working for TP USA the conservative
activist organization around the country
and they've rescinded their admission of
cash of now cash if didn't just get
admitted to Harvard because he's a
celebrity some other people who also
became celebrities from that Parkland
school shooting had pretty low grades
and they got into very good schools
because they became celebrities not true
of kyle kyle earned his way in there
you got a 1550 on his SAT which is
almost perfect he has a 3.9 GPA in high
school again almost
perfect he worked really hard he's a
very sharp kid
I mean I've I've known him a little bit
for at least a year now and I can tell
you he's he's super smart he would do
very well at Harvard
so he gets admitted this is a big deal
it can be a life-changing event for a
young teenager if you get into an elite
university it means you can have access
to certain networks you can go get
certain high-paying jobs it's just it
means a lot it's not it's not nothing
and then at the end of May one of Kyle's
political opponents posted an old Google
document in which Kyle and some of his
friends were saying the most outrageous
things they possibly could so they were
using the n-word in jokes they were
using all sorts of profanity they were
saying things eff me and the a just
saying the most grotesque and outrageous
things you can possibly say as a result
of this Harvard has rescinded his
admission because he made outrageous
comments privately with his friends in a
little chat box when he was 16 years old
so the question that Harvard needs to
ask now is does this mean that any
student who has ever said anything
outrageous or offensive at the age of 16
will lose his admission how many
students were admitted to Harvard do you
think who didn't say something
outrageous or offensive at the age of 16
how many none none none is the answer
not one single student who was admitted
to Harvard has never said something a
mean or outrageous or offensive or
racial or sexist or whatever in their
lives not one now is Harvard going to
investigate all of their other students
and figure out what they said in their G
chats when they were 16 years old I
assume Kyle Kashyap isn't the only
student matriculating into Harvard class
of 2023 who had the internet when he was
a kid I assume he's not the only one who
had google documents and G chats and
Facebook Messenger and all those things
I think if we're gonna analyze Kyle's
16-year old G chats
maybe we should analyze every other
student at that you know
how many matriculating Harvard students
have ever said the n-word even once even
as a joke because that's what this is
about this is what the left is saying he
said the n-word he said all that other
stuff but he said the n-word so he has
to be have his life ruined and be kicked
out of school how many students in that
class have said the n-word even once
even as a joke almost all of them that's
how many even once even one time maybe
you were quoting somebody maybe you were
saying it ironically maybe you were
saying it to reclaim the word for
yourself or for your friend or whatever
even one time have you ever said that
word even once yes you have
did you read Huck Finn did you say it
out loud every single one of them are
they going to be kicked out of Harvard
know how many matriculating Harvard
students have ever said eff me up the a
if that's a problem Harvard's gonna have
a homophobia case on their hands any of
the other bad words 100% of these kids
did that so forget the kids for a second
how about the Harvard admissions
committee because these aren't just the
kids going into Harvard these are the
gatekeepers these are the people who are
deciding who gets to go in who gets to
have a be part of this diverse and
inclusive community they are the most
powerful people in the whole equation do
you think any people on the Harvard
admissions committee when they were 20
or 15 16 or 10 years old do you think
any of them said the n-word even once
even as a joke I think they probably did
do you think any of them said some other
racial let's say they didn't say the N
let's say they said some other racial
slur they said Guido or Guinea or Nick
or something like that
slurs for Irish and Italian people you
think they ever said that once one time
honky slur for white people cracker slur
for white people
I think they ever said that once even
one time yes they all did it all of them
did it sure would be a shame if the Dean
of Admissions William R Fitzsimmons sure
would be a shame if it turned out that
that guy had said some offensive things
in his past when he was 16 and then we
dug them up
how many of those people could stand how
many of those people none of course none
of them could the real irony here is
that there is no evidence whatsoever
that Kyle harbours any sort of actual
racial bigotry I made this point on
Twitter and all of a sudden the lefties
came they said of course there's
evidence it's in the texts we see the
gee chats he used the n-word right I
know he did I saw he said it they did it
like 20 times in all capitals and word
n-word n-word n-word n-word but there's
no evidence that he actually harbors
racial bias or resentment or bigotry
because in that same exact sentence he
said eff me up the a so what do you
think is more likely do you think it's
more likely that these chats reflect
what Kyle really thinks and what he
really feels deep in his core and
therefore Kyle is secretly gay or do you
think that it was just a 16 year old kid
saying the most outrageous things he
possibly could for shock value as all 16
year old kids do it was the latter and
you've done similar things and so has
everybody else now there is a big irony
here because while there is no evidence
that Kyle cash of Hope has any racial
bigotry in his body at all there is a
lot of evidence that the Harvard
admissions office harbors a lot of
racial bigotry there is a major lawsuit
right now from Asian Americans who
observe that Harvard unfairly
discriminates against Asian applicants
we know that this happens this is not
some conspiracy theory or something the
Dean of Admissions himself has testified
that Harvard Doc's Asian applicants 250
points on their SAT so if you are if you
apply to Harvard and you're a black
student there is a lower bar for you
according to the admissions office
because the admissions office apparently
thinks that black applicants can't
compete or something like that because
their racial bigots if you are an Asian
applicant to Harvard there is a hand
there is a disadvantage so if you're an
Asian applicant you have to score higher
on your SAT to be considered at the same
level as students of other races there
no other word for that than racial
bigotry you can use whatever euphemism
you want affirmative action or progress
or whatever whatever you from social
justice it's race discrimination that's
what Harvard does that's not some gchat
from when you were 16 years old that's
the current policy in the admissions
office at Harvard so what happened Kyle
apologized right away when these texts
came out this was a mistake he shouldn't
have done it
he should have privately apologized to
anybody that he offended any of his
friends who were offended or any people
that he knew that he was that he had
offended of course I suspect none of
them were actually offended by Kyle
because he was just saying shocking
outrageous things did Kyle have to
apologize to his gay friends as well for
saying f me up da I don't I don't know I
don't remember that being a big issue
Kyle Kashyap does not owe a public
apology to anybody for saying the stupid
sort of things the kids say he doesn't
owe a public apology to one single
person this is the difference obviously
people should grow they should have
humility they should realize that when
you're a kid you act immature then you
grow up and you act in a mature way so
we don't want to say he should be proud
of what he said no of course not what he
said it was stupid
it's what 16 year olds say and if he
privately offended anybody okay deal
with that he doesn't owe anybody a
public apology for being a stupid kid
it's ridiculous he should not have
bought into the leftist premise that he
owed the public an apology he didn't I
think it made it worse some
conservatives now are attacking him from
another angle they're attacking him for
wanting to go to Harvard in the first
place and this is fairly compelling
argument cuz I don't care for Harvard
and I'm pretty disenchanted with all of
higher education at the moment they say
who cares who cares if you go to Harvard
Harvard's stupid forget about Harvard
what they say is conservatives talk a
good game about the universities being
worthless and pointless and just as
worthless credential but then all of
them go to Harvard Yale Princeton
Stanford they go they all go to those
top schools right what what those
conservative critics are missing is is
the actual point here
the reason that the anti conservative
bias of schools like Harvard matters is
because a Harvard degree does matter and
that's what this is by the way this is
an excuse this has nothing to do with
the n-word it has nothing to do with gee
chats when you were 16 this is just an
excuse for Kyle's political opponents to
get Harvard to kick him out for being a
conservative that's all this is about
this is about nothing else and the
reason that that anti conservative bias
of these institutions matters is that
having that degree from Harvard matters
it means you will make more money or
you're able to make more money you have
a better chance of getting into a better
graduate school or a law school or a
medical school you get access to better
alumni networks old boys club you you
just get advantages from this even if
you don't learn anything by the way even
if you have a kind of poultry education
there you will still get access to a
terrific network is that because Harvard
is the oldest university in America now
this problem for Kyle is there's no
problem that he wanted to go to Harvard
there's no problem that he apologized
and said please Harvard please take me
back don't do this to me it's actually
incumbent on us as conservatives to keep
the heat up on these universities we'll
explain how in a second but first there
are a lot of things in life that aren't
right there are a lot of things in life
that are right like kicking a kid out of
college because he said something stupid
when he was 16 doesn't make a lot of
sense does it a lot of things in life
that are not right we look around and
today in this day and age up is down but
black is white
two plus two equals seven a lot of
things don't seem right in the culture
one of the things that doesn't seem
right especially is paying too much for
your phone bill and that is very wrong
but thanks to Mint mobile you don't have
to overpay for Wireless anymore with
mint mobile you can cut out your old
wireless bill and bring it down to 15
bucks a month
mint has reimagined Wireless they make
it easy and online only which means they
pass on significant savings directly to
you you can save thousands of dollars a
year with mint mobile and you won't
sacrifice quality service now I know
that you don't believe me when I say
that cuz I didn't believe it when I
first heard it so there's no way they're
gonna be all these secret hidden fees
it's going to
being $100 a month no I'm telling you
mint mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down to 15 bucks a month
what are you pay your propane like 90
bucks a month right now use your own
phone with any min mobile plan keep your
old number along with all your old
contacts with mint mobile you choose
between 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data and you stop paying for unlimited
data that's how big big cellular gets
you is they charge you for all this data
that you're never ever going to use
you're on Wi-Fi almost all the time
anyway every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talking text do it you're
gonna love it and by the way if you're
not 100% satisfied mint mobile has you
covered
with their 7 day money-back guarantee no
risk at all ditch your old wireless bill
start saving with mint mobile to get
your new wireless plan for just fifteen
bucks a month that's a lot of savings
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mint mobile comm slash
Knowles Canada wles mint mobile.com
slash Knowles Keo wles cut your wireless
bill down to fifteen bucks a month and
get free shipping on your mint mobile
plant mint mobile comm slash Knowles we
shouldn't blame Kyle for wanting to go
to Harvard or for trying to salvage his
Harvard admission we should keep up the
intensity here I mean the Conservatives
should stop letting the left run through
all of our institutions this is what
they do they take over our universities
they take over Hollywood they take over
the mainstream media the left never
gives an inch on any of these so why
should we why should we say oh forget
about Harvard no way Harvard's a
valuable commodity a Harvard degree is a
valuable thing we shouldn't surrender it
to the left so how do we fight back
first of all we should dig up every
single thing that this Dean of
Admissions has ever written or published
everything you know the advantage of
believing in grace and repentance in
politics is that I'll face up to
anything that I've ever said anything
I've said on this show or on tweets or
in columns or whatever I will face up to
anything that I have said and in some
cases I'll say oh yeah that was stupid I
don't agree with that anymore
in some cases I'll say well yeah I don't
know maybe I'll stand by that a little
bit in some cases I'll say oh I changed
my mind
I'm perfectly willing to do that because
I believe in a society that has grace
and repentance and in which people
mature by the impossible standards that
Harvard is now
no man can possibly stand no one not a
single person there's a line in the
Merchant of Venice by Shakespeare the
line is in the course of justice none of
us should see salvation we do pray for
mercy and that same prayer doth teach us
all to render the deeds of Mercy in it
is if all you're focusing on is justice
or I guess in this case social justice
none of us will see salvation we will be
totally destroyed because we all fall
and sin and do stupid things when we
were 16 now ironically the only way that
we can show the need for mercy here is
to hold Harvard to their own impossible
standards we should dig up as much as we
can on whatever the Dean of Admissions
William R Fitzsimmons ever put in his g
chats when he was 16 years old he's a
little older than that so maybe we'll
have to look up columns that he wrote
when he was a kid maybe we'll have to
look up a correspondence that he's had
as he's been an adult because something
tells me he has not had a perfect 100
percent a series of communications and
essays and articles and emails something
tells me that he said some things that
maybe he regrets and we should dig them
up if they're gonna hold to Kyle to that
standard if Harwood were smart they
would let Kyle in because this is going
to increase a lot of pressure we should
keep the pressure up on this Harvard
race discrimination case we should keep
this up very very hard the Supreme Court
and the other courts watch the poll
numbers they watch what's going on in
the news this is how the left has won a
lot of victories at the Supreme Court we
should keep that up as well we'll keep
following this story we don't want to
let Kyle hang out to dry here moving on
to a different story but another one
actually that involves the Supreme Court
over the weekend President Trump has
endorsed a constitutional amendment to
prohibit flag burning this has always
been a big touchy issue the this new
constitutional amendment has been
suggested by representatives Steve
Womack of Arkansas and Steve Daines of
Montana Senator Steve Daines
and so they put this idea out right now
it's legal to burn an American flag this
was upheld by the Supreme Court in 1989
in a case called Texas v Johnson and the
court found that burning an American
flag is protected speech under the First
Amendment what this constitutional
amendment would do is specifically ban
the burning of the American flag
President Trump tweeted out he said all
in for Senator Steve Daines as he
proposes an amendment for a strong Bamm
on burning our American flag a real no
brainer every pundit in the country
immediately when Trump said this left
right in the center came out and said
this is a terrible idea it's on American
it's indefensible we have to burn flags
we must let people burn flags there's no
argument on the other side actually
there is there's a very good argument
for this constitutional amendment we'll
make that in just a second what is the
argument for flag burning what is the
argument to protect the right of people
to burn the flag every one of these
pundits invoked Antonin Scalia who put
it very well he said this I would not
allow people to go about burning the
American flag however we have a First
Amendment which says that the right of
free speech shall not be abridged and it
is addressed in particular to speech
critical of the government I mean that
was the main kind of speech that tyrants
would seek to suppress burning the flag
is a form of expression speech doesn't
just mean written words or oral words it
could be semaphore and burning a flag is
a symbol that expresses an idea I hate
the government the government is unjust
whatever listen to the argument he's
made this argument many times he said
look if I were king this is another life
I'm paraphrasing but only slightly he
said if I were king I would throw in
prison every scruffy bearded
sandal-wearing weirdo who burns the
American flag but I am NOT the king so
all the the left and the sort of liberal
conservatives are heard here is we have
a First Amendment that protects the
right to burn the flag and so therefore
it's a good thing that we can protect
the right to burn the flag that's not
what Scalia said he said if I were in
charge I would prohibit burning the
American
I was actually I was covering a rally a
revolutionary communist rally just a
week or two ago and they burned American
flags there I'd never seen an American
flag burn it's a horrific sight it is
you don't know what it's like until you
see it in person so Scalia makes the
argument he says it actually makes the
argument in the Supreme Court case in
1989 Texas v Johnson he joined some
liberals he broke from some
conservatives and he says that the First
Amendment protects the right to burn the
flag and I agree with him he's totally
right with that justice Brennan wrote
the argument for the court there
defending flag burning he wrote if there
is a bedrock principle underlying the
First Amendment it is that the
government may not prohibit the
expression of an idea simply because
society finds the idea itself offensive
or disagreeable we have not recognized
an exception to this principle even
where our flag has been involved we are
tempted to say and this is where they go
too far we are tempted to say in fact
that the flags deservedly cherished
place in our community will be
strengthened not weakened by our holding
today our decision is a reaffirmation of
the principles of freedom and
inclusiveness that the flag best
reflects and of the conviction that our
toleration of criticism such as
Johnson's is a sign and source of our
strength so it's serially flag-burning
is flag bernie is our strength or
whatever ridiculous line they have okay
so that's that as a cut and dry argument
that's a cut and dry argument for
allowing flag burning what's the
argument against flag burning even from
the First Amendment perspective
justice Rehnquist and white and O'Connor
dissented and Rehnquist wrote the
dissent he said quote in holding this
Texas statute unconstitutional the court
ignores Justice Holmes as familiar
aphorism that a page of history is worth
a volume of logic for more than 200
years the American flag has occupied a
unique position as a symbol of our
nation a uniqueness that justifies a
governmental prohibition against flag
burning in the way respondent Johnson
did here so he's saying there's a unique
place right here for the flag and then
he goes on and he I love this line about
how the importance of history here
rather than just all doctrine and he
gives the history of the place of the
American flag in American his
Streep he then says the flag symbolizes
the nation in peace as well as in war in
1931 Congress declared the star-spangled
banner to be our national anthem no
other American symbol has been as
universally honored as the flag so even
you think our national anthem is the
flag the what is a flag a flag is a
symbol of the country that's all it is
it's not a piece of cloth it's not it's
a symbol of the whole country and as
such our our flag is such a symbol of
our country that our national anthem
itself is the flag it is the
star-spangled banner it's a symbol but
it's not merely a symbol it is a symbol
of the nation which precedes the
Constitution and this is the key here
this is the conservative argument for
this constitutional amendment which i
think is a perfectly fine idea we'll get
to that in a second but first we've got
to say goodbye to facebook and youtube
head over to daily wire.com and
subscribe ten bucks a month 100 dollars
for an annual membership you get me at
the end reclaim and show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you have to ask questions
in the mail bag get all that great stuff
and also you truth-loving cigar smoking
whiskey and by being seekers of laughs
and insight pay attention because we are
taking backstage live we are taking that
show on the road
August 21st to the Terrace Theatre in
Long Beach California ben shapiro daily
wire god-king jeremy boring andrew
Clavin and little ol me will be live on
stage discussing the winners and losers
of politics and pop culture and doing
our best to answer your burning
questions from the audience also will be
selling merch by we of course I mean me
because they're probably gonna make me
go work on merch boots duty tickets go
on sale to the public this Friday but
only daily wire subscribers will get
premium are oh so there's all starting
tomorrow June 18 that through Thursday
the 20th so subscribe right now get your
tickets tomorrow it's gonna be an
incredible event so go join us and I
look forward to seeing you there daily
wire.com you get everything you know you
get the leftist ears tumblr you're gonna
need it more and more these days
especially if we get an anti flag
burning amendment go to daily we're calm
we'll be right back
so the argument that the Conservatives
rehnquist at least is making in the
Texas v Johnson case is that the flag is
not just some regular idea it's not just
some symbol it's a special symbol and
therefore it supersedes the First
Amendment so he says Congress and the
states have enacted many laws regulating
the use of the flag how the flag can be
used since at least 1907 and it's
therefore it's not just merely a symbol
he says the flag is not simply another
idea or point of view competing for
recognition in the marketplace of ideas
millions and millions of Americans
regard it with an almost mystical
reverence regardless of what sort of
social political or philosophical
beliefs they may have I cannot agree
that the First Amendment invalidates the
act of Congress and the laws of 48 of
the 50 states which make criminal the
public burning of the flag so that's his
argument he says this is super special
it overrides the First Amendment I don't
agree with that I agree with Scalia in
this case and some of the Liberals that
the First Amendment permits the burning
of the American flag it is clearly
expressive speech it is clearly
political speech it's clearly protected
by the First Amendment however if there
is a constitutional amendment to
prohibit flag burning there's no
constitutional problem I agree if you
made a law right now that outlawed flag
burning I would say that's
unconstitutional I wouldn't support it
but if you have an amendment that says
in the specific case of the American
flag you can't desecrate it you can't
burn it that is against the law there's
no problem doesn't doesn't make it
unconstitutional it makes it explicitly
constitutional and and I don't see any
reason not to do that or conservatives
so if we gone so far in this direction
that now we're celebrating the right to
burn the flag
there's no good being accomplished by
burning the flag by the way it's not as
though plenty of
entries don't have laws against burning
the flag plenty of perfectly fine
countries flag burning right now today
is illegal in Argentina Austria Croatia
Finland France Germany India Israel
Japan Malaysia Mexico New Zealand
Portugal Serbia South Korea Sweden
Switzerland Ukraine and Uruguay at least
all those countries some of them not
terribly developed some of them very
developed some of them quite westernized
some quite liberal they they all have
laws against flag burning do you know
what country doesn't have any laws
against flag burning Canada what who do
you want to be more like Croatia Finland
France India Japan Israel or Canada I
don't want to be like Canada there are
actually some countries in Denmark and
Norway it is illegal to burn their own
national flag but it is illegal to burn
other national flags which it's like
exactly the opposite what if you're
gonna have this kind of that sort of
silly law and we'd invert it guys what
are you doing this is a perfectly common
idea why are there laws against flag
burning because burning a flag is
heinous it is a heinous act of national
and cultural suicide I am perfectly fine
with a constitutional amendment banning
flag burning I think that is perfectly
okay thing to do it is by definition not
unconstitutional and why am i ok with it
because the nation comes before the
constitution you can have a country
without a constitution there have been
many countries without constitutions the
vast majority of countries in the
history of the world have not had a
constitution our country our own country
from 1620 up until the late 18th century
didn't have a constitution for most of
England's history it didn't have a
constitution you can have a country
without a constitution you can't have a
constitution without a country
a constitution with the camp at a
country doesn't mean anything by that I
mean the nation is the basis of the
Constitution our our First Amendment
which we all cherish
does not exist without America and the
flag is a symbol of America the flag is
not a symbol of the First Amendment
though if it were it would be just as
incoherent to burn the flag as it
already is let's say that the flag were
a symbol of the First Amendment and you
say see I have the right to burn this
flag because of my First Amendment and
this flag actually represents my First
Amendment and then you set the flag on
fire what did you do you just set on
fire you're on First Amendment right you
destroyed your right to burn the flag by
burning the flag in the first place well
it's it's even more the case that
because the flag represents the country
without this country you don't get your
right to your First Amendment you don't
get your right to free speech the reason
that kneeling kneeling for the national
anthem disrespecting the national anthem
disrespecting the flag is so stupid it's
so profoundly stupid is that without the
country you don't have that right in the
first place
without that flag without what that flag
represents which is America you have no
First Amendment you have no freedom of
speech you don't get to burn the flag
there's this a line that GK Chesterton
used he said there is a thought that
stops thought and that is the only
thought that ought to be stopped that's
what I'm seeing here in the in the flag
when you burn the flag what you are
burning is the country not only
everything the country stands for
but everything the country is everything
about the country that gives way to all
of the things that you like about it the
First Amendment and this civil liberty
and this economic prosperity you're
burning it all up
it is totally incoherent it doesn't make
any sense and I think it is perfectly
reasonable to pass a constitutional
amendment of prohibiting that it's a
grand old flag it's a high-flying flag
and forever in peace makes you wait and
I'm perfectly happy to answer any
conservative who has become so obsessed
with this idea of liberalism without any
limits on it that there for some reason
celebrating the right to burn a flag I
agree look I agree with all of the
arguments from the First Amendment I
agree today it is perfectly
legal and constitutional to burn a flag
but if you pass a constitutional
amendment it's all good and by the way
if we if we could start passing more
constitutional amendments it would show
that we act our country really is alive
we really do have some control over our
government Antonin Scalia that one that
they all keep invoking he said before he
died that the one regret he has about
the Constitution is that it's not easier
to make amendments so this great idea it
says as good as an amendment as I've
ever seen
I want to turn also speaking of wrapping
yourself in the flag in American history
I have to turn to the 2020 race and Pete
Budaj edge because Pete Buddha judge
this guy is such a slick smart
politician Peabody judge was doing an
interview and he's putting out material
from Axios on HBO which is helping all
that 20 20 candidates he was asked if
it's gonna matter that he's gay how
that's gonna affect him and what that
means for American history his answer
was perfect Republicans claim that John
Kerry was a traitor in Vietnam that
Barack Obama was a Muslim if you were to
win the nomination they'll say you're
too young too liberal too gay to be
commander-in-chief you are young you are
liberal you are gay how are you
responding I'll respond by explaining
where I want to leave this country
people will elect the person who will
make the best president and we have had
excellent presidents who have been young
we have had excellent presidents who
have been liberal I would imagine we've
probably had excellent presidents who
were gay we just didn't know which ones
you believe that we've had a gay
commander-in-chief I mean statistically
it's almost certain and like in your
reading of history like do you believe
you know who they were my gaydar don't
even work that well on the president let
alone retroactive Lee but one can only
assume that's the case my first reaction
watching him was was one word it was
what what do you mean statistically
almost certainly we've had gay
presidents you can't you can't name the
gay presidents but you're certain that
we've had them you don't know which ones
but certain statistically what does that
mean so just that word statistically
what he's doing is he's cloaking his
ideology in this guise of science
is what the left always does because
they worship at the altar of science so
they say yes I'm I'm not telling you
historically there were gay presidents
but scientifically there have to have
been can you name them well no of course
not what statistics are you talking
about what are the statistics on gay
presidents there there aren't any
statistics on gay presidents there's no
statistical textbook or some data set on
gay presidents you're just making that
up but Pete Buddha judge because he
knows his base he's using the scientific
language to make it seem perfectly
normal and he does it in this very
monotone way goes yeah well of course
hey I'm just perfectly reasonable what
he said is a pretty radical thing he
said we've definitely had gay presidents
that's news to me I don't remember gay
presidents so that this is the first
lesson is just being very matter-of-fact
and dress up your language in science he
also won't get specific very very smart
because when he says we've almost
certainly had gay presidents what's he
referring to the most obvious answer is
James Buchanan this is the president
that everybody always says he's the gay
one he's guaranteed to be the gay
president he was the 15th President of
the United States he was a Democrat he
was disastrous and some people say that
he was gay he led to the panic of 1857
he presided over bleeding Kansas a
horrific early early stage an event in
what would lead to the civil war he
presided over secession and he presided
over the the beginning of that war now
the reason they say that Buchanan was
gay is because he's our only bachelor
president so it's the same reason you
know people say that Lindsey Graham is
gay because he never got married they
say the same thing about James Buchanan
he's the only president who was a
bachelor he did have a romantic
encounter with a woman when he was
younger but then that was the only woman
he ever showed any interest in he also
had a close relationship with a really
William Rufus King who was this
politician and it was sometimes referred
to in Washington circles as Miss Nancy
or aunt fancy these were terms for an
effeminate man sort of like the 19th
century version of being a little light
in the loafers and so there were rumors
I
yes that he he was a gay guy or he at
least surrounded himself with gay guys
or at least that he was a confirmed
bachelor so that's one in now of course
I don't think people judge wants to
claim him one because it's so
presumptuous that becomes the story
Buddha judge calls James Buchanan gay
and and that leads Buddha judge all the
way from the news cycle that he wants
the other one is he was a horrific
President and Democrats of Buddha judge
probably doesn't want to draw any
comparisons between himself and the guy
who started the Civil War the the next
president that they sometimes call gay
is actually the next president is
Abraham Lincoln and the gay Republican
group is called the Log Cabin
Republicans cuz Abe Lincoln was born in
a log cabin and they sort of tipped
their hat to this story that he was gay
there's no evidence that Abe Lincoln was
gay when he was a young man he shared a
bed briefly with another guy this was
common at the time because people didn't
have a lot of money and so they would
sleep in the same bed together I've
slept in plenty of beds with dudes maybe
I'm giving too much information but I
think everybody has you know if you go
you're like on a road trip and there's
only one bed you got to share the room
or I mean this that sort of thing
happens all the time that's what
happened with Abraham Lincoln and and I
don't know maybe he thinks there have
been other gay presidents who knows I I
couldn't couldn't possibly say you know
but who knows but my second reaction to
this was that this was brilliant I mean
this was absolutely a brilliant way to
handle it why because the question to
Buddha judge was are you too young are
you too liberal are you too gay to be
President and so what the kind of stupid
leftist would answer is well we should
have a young president it's about damn
time we have a young president well it's
about damn time we have a liberal
president it's about damn time we have a
gay president that's the stupid leftist
reaction where you claim victimhood and
you say I've been oppressed and okay
that's the knee-jerk reaction of our age
the smarter reaction is oh we have a
long tradition in America of liberal
presidents a long tradition of young
presidents a long tradition
of gay presidents it's like what are you
talking we do we know for a fact we
haven't had any gay presidents we don't
know the sexual desires of every single
president you know but none of them
behaved in a gay way or had a gay
husband or so I think we just know we
didn't but he says it with a straight
face because the way to change America
the way to push your innovative
progressive platform is not to set
yourself up in opposition to America
it's to pretend that America has
secretly been this way all the time
and you're just bringing out the best in
America oh yes the presidents have
always been gay they're like okay all
right it's really brilliant I mean this
is what the civil rights movement did
they said I mean the reason we talk
about Martin Luther King is because
Martin Luther King didn't say America's
an awful racist terrible irredeemable
place like Malcolm X did he said America
needs to live up to her Creed America
needs to live up to her traditions and
that got everyone to buy into it
same thing with women's suffrage and the
women's rights movement this has been
all a part of America we just haven't
lived up to it yet and now we're going
to live up to our Creed and that's what
what people judge is gonna do this guy
is dangerous for Republicans I mean he
is a sharp politician I initially wrote
off a small-town mayor from South Bend
who is the mayor of a hundred thousand
people or something not ready to be
President but he's really good and one
of his pitches especially if he's if
he's pitching himself for vice president
is that he'll be it'll be great to watch
him go up against Mike Pence who the
left is completely unfairly painted is
some sort of anti-gay bigot or something
like that really sharp guy he's playing
everything right and I suspect he's
gonna keep rising up in the polls one
thing I have to get to before we go is
this little clip from Donald Trump's
interview with George Stephanopoulos
which just leaked out today it was kind
of some of the extra footage there and
it shows an interaction that is actually
very telling about Donald Trump
so Trump is talking to Stephanopoulos
he's giving an answer and then his
budget or rather his former budget
director and now his chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney coughs in the background and
Trump stops the footage stops the
Amma's says we got a reset because he
was coughing listen to this at some
point I hope they get it you're gonna
turn it over no at some point I might
but at some point up they get it because
it's safe enough it's a fantastic
financial statement it's a fantastic
financial statement and let's do that
over he's coughing in the middle of my
aunt's yeah okay I don't like that you
know your chief of staff you get a
coffee please
just to change the shot I'm sorry okay
you want to do that a little differently
then yeah so at some point so at some
point I look forward to frankly I want
I'd like to have people see my financial
statement because he's phenomenal no
it's not up to me it's up to lawyers
it's up to everything else but they're
asking for things that they should never
be asking for that they've never asked
another president for they want to go
through every deal that I've ever done
they've what they're doing is a
descriptor they're trying to do step
step-step they want to keep it going as
long as possible to try and demean and
hurt as much as possible so they can
possibly win the presidential election
this is a very telling exchange and it I
hope puts to rest one of this stupidest
takes on Donald Trump which is that he's
this completely undisciplined wacko
lunatic who doesn't know what's going on
and he shoots from the hip and he's only
just belching various emotions all the
times no this guy knows how to work a
camera this is a pretty calculated guy
how do I know that because he's giving
this answer that he wants to give to
Stephanopoulos and here Zach off in the
room and Trump's a showbiz guy he had 15
seasons of a Network show hit network
show and he knows that that sound is
gonna ruin that clip and they're not
gonna be able to use it so he says I
stopped we got you can't you can't COFF
on set what are you doing get out of
here if you're gonna call fun set this
is okay it was like alright let's reset
it maybe we'll do it a little
differently he's talking like a guy
either who's in a movie or at least just
who's doing a nonfiction TV show is
there I kill reset and then the guys
reset and then the camera guy screws up
and he moves and Trump catches that
again and he resets all right guys here
we go
then they do it and he
resets and then Trump gives the message
that he wants to the American people and
he gives it as though it's right off the
cuff he gives it like he's in a reality
TV show and look and this and that it's
not like he's giving this perfectly
scripted monologue but he is letting you
know you the American people the people
who watch ABC News just a lot more
people than watch cable news or Fox News
he's telling them what he wants them to
hear this is a disciplined guy this is a
guy with situational awareness and this
is a guy who knows how to communicate no
accidents no accidents here I people are
still going to pretend that he's this
total buffoon who just accidentally has
succeeded it at the highest levels of
everything he's ever tried but this was
more revealing than the Billy Bush tape
which was a guy engaging in locker room
talk when he thought he was off camera
this is much more telling about how
Trump's brain works and how he views
politics in the Oval Office and imagery
and how he views mass communications
that's our show oh I should point out by
the way Sarah Sanders is stepping down
as press secretary and some people have
suggested that maybe she should be
replaced by me I don't I don't know
who's been suggesting this someone
pointed out that my new Twitter handle
is potential White House press secretary
Michael Knowles that's a total
coincidence that's an old nickname that
I had in high school it's just it's just
a thing but you know it's funny that
they've suggested it I do think you know
if my country called on me I would
certainly serve and my experience of
dealing with shrieking leftists on
campuses around the country has prepared
me to deal with Jim Acosta but mr.
president you have my phone number you
know I'll keep you posted you know when
the phone rings that's our show come
back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys over on the mat
wall show today some Republicans are
once again trying to ban flag burning
because this is something we have to do
every few years it seems but is flag
barn burning a form of speech is it a
protected speech is it covered by the
First Amendment I say yes obviously on
all three counts but we'll we'll take a
look at that subject and talk about it
also we'll look at a very powerful yet
heartbreaking and tragic video of an
incident that transpired outside of an
abortion clinic recently and finally
Taylor Swift has a new song out it is
incredibly boring yet obnoxious at the
same time and that is an impressive
combination which Taylor Swift seems to
have protected or perfected I should say
so we'll talk about that today as well
on the Matt Walsh show